did I tell you about
um Harry Styles movie the policeman yeah
my policeman yeah I saw you were uh yeah
that was so cool that they put you in
like almost full body yeah yeah honorary
Latino yeah no you should tell us what
the drip was did you see that no the the
[ __ ] brand name was uh something
Latino
and so it's a men men like they reposted
the picture of me and it was like men of
it's like a it's like a name it's like
first I gotta find it I should probably
know
what I was trying to make a joke yeah
guys wait what was the joke Cody went to
see my policeman they put him in full
Kevlar with a body cam courtesy of the
Chattanooga police department suited him
out head to toe why he had combat boots
he had a sidearm flashlight various
accessories and attachments yo speaking
of Harry Styles what's up with that girl
on Tick Tock who was like I spent 10
grand I was Finn to be in the pit wait
what you see that no it was this girl
who said I spent 10 grand at the Harry
Styles concert it's like something
something my friend said let's go open
the nosebleeds and I said no way I'm
finna be in the pit of Harry Styles yeah
wait what's funny about that because
it's like this white girl and she was
she just said I'm finna be in the pit
out of nowhere yeah yeah it was
extremely contrived yeah I'm finna being
the pit it was great oh that's cringe
grating yeah dude so the the designer's
name is style underscore Latino oh nice
so they they said men of style Latino
and so everyone responding like dude
know you're a Latino
it's like damn
nice to see you know fellow Latino
did no idea
oh
yeah dude
but um
anyway so that's the brand name
they weren't saying that I was Latino
yeah yeah yeah and I wasn't saying that
either yeah but people misconstrued it
yeah that's cool man but anyways you
didn't ask to be Latina yeah exactly
exactly yeah cool the movie
um
it's just like
I mean the movie was good actually I
really enjoyed it yeah hairstyles wasn't
I and I was like reading reviews before
and uh you know a lot of people are like
a lot of critics like hated it because
they were like he doesn't deserve you
know like oh man his acting needs so
much work he actually played the
character really well but there's just
like full-on
like intense gay sex scenes yeah
in that movie that's the stuff being
hard the whole time
you're breaked up in there turn the [ __ ]
off now you know my favorite part is
about a movie that was my first movie
premiere that I've ever been to yeah and
you know we walked the red carpet it's
like so everyone's like you know yeah I
mean that [ __ ] is [ __ ] stressful yeah
so stressful what part I mean you know
we did I know I guess we've done well
we've walked red carpets before like
yeah the Spotify party and [ __ ] like
that yeah
you know that feeling when you're
walking down they're all like over here
over and I was Kelsey's plus one so I
wasn't even on the thing sick
so we walked onto the carpet and all the
people taking pictures had hurt like
there was a person with an iPad holding
her name up so they were like Kelsey
look over here Kelsey look over here and
I was kind of like
where should where do you want me to
look where should I stand I just felt
like a puppy yeah like like just sitting
beside Kelsey and then
like everyone's taking pictures
and it's like all like there was like 50
photographers because everyone was
waiting for Harry right right so there's
so many Paparazzi there right so
everyone wants to like look crazy and
you know like make a statement and then
you walk in the theater and everyone
sits in these tiny little theater seats
yep in these crazy ass outfits I walked
in there's this guy like in a lime in a
neon green suit with no shirt on
underneath
crazy outfit it's looking fly just
sitting in a tiny seat eating popcorn
that's everyone they come in all like
Grand and everyone's like squeezed in
excuse me excuse me yeah and it's just a
normal theater yep like a normal movie
watching experience yeah my second time
being to the theater before that's so
cool dude damn
and uh yeah good thing no one came and
shot that place
I mean you laugh but that's what I was
thinking the whole time yeah I know
I mean it was cool I don't know well no
one would have shot it up because you
know Harry was there exactly he's a
policeman now yeah
[Music]
Harry would have we can't we can't shoot
it up yeah Harry's him here's a cop he's
a fully trained cop now
the stupidest joke
are you just [ __ ]
freeze enjoy the movie
damn
oh my God you went up
you wanna I came with the Swift dad joke
and then you you came in there with the
worst
[ __ ] baseball dad
holy [ __ ]
freeze enjoy the movie no I'm kidding
okay I'll mess it enjoy it listen I'll
be over here I'll be over here if you
want some popsicles he did he went on
stage before the movie and gave
you know some [ __ ] speech damn it
was like it was like it's such a funny
Dynamic dude him being an actor yeah I
feel like
he probably could have an acting career
because he's not bad and he's a good
looking guy yeah but I think he's so
famous that it's going to be just such a
hindrance yeah because like this really
was it was like a pretty great story and
the other actor was [ __ ] incredible
and that I mean all the leads were
amazing and the director was really good
and the scenery was amazing and it was
shot really nice
so then he they come in the director
comes in and then the other leads come
in and they all give this like nice
speech and then Harry walks in and like
the front like
20 rows are like oh
I actually said that
[ __ ] director and the rest of the
people and I'm so proud of you Harry
cool I was just like oh man this feels
weird yeah and he was being all trying I
love you too
it's like you're not on stage at a
concert this is like another thing you
know just felt [ __ ] weird he just
grabs the microphone just snaps right
back into it yeah
he's like a lot of you notice like so
you look after yourself you know you're
proud of you but I'm proud of you I'm
proud of you for taking care of you
kind of reminds me of strawberries
perhaps watermelon
nothing like a little bit of sugar to
get you going right yeah what up melon
sugar yeah
what are you doing just doing that [ __ ]
on set
you don't know you're beautiful
let's go a little One Direction
you like strawberry
shut that [ __ ] up man do the line do the
lines
do the lines we rehearse yeah on a
summer evening yo shut the [ __ ] up dude
be quiet
damn
yeah it was it was yeah it was
it was definitely an experience so how
did he react when you threw your
underwear up on stage he was pretty
receptive to it again they took him I
mean he basically just gave it a couple
you know like that and he's like Cody
nice Cody no yeah is that Savage yeah
it's a Dior smells like uh
like a sushi restaurant
like music from a sushi restaurant
[Music]
I barely know that song I barely know
that you watch a music video for it nah
I feel like you'd like it yeah yeah
watch it with no volume
I mean maybe we could watch it
can we start the bonus wait wait why are
you rolling your eyes this is a funny
ass thing to say yeah let's watch it
with no volume yeah yeah that [ __ ] goes
crazy on mute
oh you are staying in the hood with this
one
look at me everything
they're never not funny anytime anyone
says something negative with a fire
Emoji next to it it [ __ ] me up
seriously dude I like little pumps yo
delete this
yo unrelease this unreleased this is the
best one
release
yeah I'm putting out music and for
someone to say take it back it's so
funny
it's so funny oh [ __ ] I'll delete this I
just feel like that movie like Harry I
think Harry was getting some [ __ ] for
like queerbaiting and he's like I'll
just [ __ ] show you queerbaiting yeah
and then he [ __ ] a guy like this what
I'm official yeah dude this movie was
like crafted to get the maximum amount
of views from gen Z not that it's bad
but I mean it was it was crazy like I'm
like I there are like rumors that he's
like spy or whatever so it's just so
graphic for no reason but it's just like
the first scene he's just like just
[ __ ] topping something crazy it's
just like the porn angle yeah
POV I'm just
the opening thing yeah he finishes his
speech he's like so this this story is
about love something as old as time it's
the top of his head so please please
enjoy the movie I I enjoyed making this
so much with the team here that
absolutely sounding theme and enjoy
what the hell was that
I'll try to make that [ __ ]
what was that yeah explain what was that
you know like the you know oh the the
that's what I was trying to do
the Blowfish noise
damn it just opens bro just
Peter oh [ __ ]
where's the guy yeah I'm so proud of you
Harry